hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to another code review the
series in which you guys send me your
code and i take a look at it the last
two episodes we've been looking at c
sharp code so i thought i would bring it
back to c plus for this episode here
today we are going to be looking at a
minecraft clone can you believe we still
haven't done this to be completely
honest i actually have to go back and
check that we haven't done a minecraft
clone yet just because it feels like
something that would have come up by now
but i think we were just too busy
looking at ray traces that people were
sending in speaking of which i have a
new ray tracing series the link will be
up there if you are interested in
learning about ray tracing and how to
actually maybe write some decently
performing code i like the stuff we've
been looking at in this series sorry
then definitely check out that series
but anyway minecraft so east van horvath
probably butchering that name has sent
in a minecraft clone in opengl called gl
craft very clever dear cherno
please review my project see this is
this is how you start a code review
email i want to learn how video games
work and how to create one so i
recreated a very basic version of
minecraft i'm isti a 20 years old
university student it was a great
experience to create a game from scratch
i learned a lot i watched a lot of
shouno videos for help in his prayer
like how he calls them turner video not
your videos i watched a lot of journal
videos
for help and inspiration i even checked
out the hazel 2d source to see how
something should be implemented but i
did not copy paste anything i promise
i don't know if this is a reference to
like that bloom shader that someone just
outright copied and pasted but whatever
there are only two types of programmers
those who steal other people's code and
those who lie about it i don't think a
single program is possibly the first
programmer in existence has probably
gone through their lives without
actually just you know stealing stealing
a piece of someone's code just you know
under the table while no one notices but
anyway it looks like this person has
probably just been you know used it for
kind of inspiration and maybe like
design guidance or something like that i
didn't create a proper engine for the
game because i think that the
architecture that i created was
sufficient for the game that i had in
mind
okay i think from reading this might be
a good idea to kind of focus on the
architecture of this actual code and
talk a little bit about what it's like
to actually architect a game instead of
architecting an engine because these
days
everything is built on game engines
right like most games that come out
obviously like they're not just like
one-off kind of let's open up you know c
plus plus and just write a game and the
game contains the engine ish it's not
really the engine you just write a game
in c plus plus without using some kind
of engine like most games that come out
these days are not made from scratch in
the sense that they are made using tools
that already exist
even if that tool was specifically made
to make a game so for that reason i'm
actually really interested to take a
look at this and see
how this kind of game has been made
because it's a very different decision
when you're riding an engine and you're
trying to make everything generic and
abstract like all of the kind of core
components away but then when you're
making a game you can be a a lot more
kind of free
with like writing specific code instead
of generic code which in a lot of cases
is really good but also even if you
aren't writing an engine i think that
there has to be
obviously some kind of balance between
like writing opengl code like i don't
know gl draw elements or something
in
places where nothing involving the
renderer should be there at all right so
you can still obviously make the mistake
of coupling code and like intertwining
code in places that where it shouldn't
be and just because you are actually
architecting you know your software well
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
trying to abstract it into an engine so
anyway this will be interesting to take
a look at a house
there's a there's a distinct lack of
ambient occlusion here which makes me
upset thanks i'll check it out
i love these suggestions all right i'm
just skimming through the repository
here link will be in the description
below if you guys want to check out this
project for yourselves as well building
the project how to build in c line we're
not going to be using sant lan
how to build it using so okay so cmake
will build it using cmake i guess chunks
are hollow on the inside so most of the
blocks that are not visible are not sent
to the gpu that's very very important if
you're making a minecraft game otherwise
there's just too much data to render and
almost none of it is actually even
needed each vertex in a chunk is only
four bytes long to make the game as
memory efficient as possible on the gpu
side
every each of each vertex in a chunk
is only four bytes oh okay
so i i expect this means that he's
packed the data
because like you know if you're drawing
everything and everything is like a one
by one meter block you don't really need
like you know to store everything
in maximum kind of precision because you
know that you're going to be rendering
you know triangles in a certain format
and they're essentially going to be laid
out in this kind of voxel grid so a good
example is like traditionally if you
have like a 3d model you might want to
have like you know three floats xyz
representing like a vertex right and so
three floats would be 12 bytes and that
would just be a single vertex and so if
we were in fact drawing like a cube we
would obviously need like eight unique
vertex positions and if we factor in
like normals we might end up with like
24 different vertices however
technically speaking if all we're
drawing is an actual like cube and the
whole world is made up of cubes all we
really need to know is like the integer
coordinate of that cube which could be
encoded in a number of ways it could be
local to chunk space as well if you
wanted it to be i guess that would mean
that you didn't have to store very large
numbers i mean you could literally you
could probably get away with making i
mean entertain this idea if you will if
it's local to chunk space and chunks are
like 16 by 16 then you really only need
like four bits to to encode that chunk
coordinate because four bits gets you
like zero to 15 and that can be like the
index so four for four so you basically
end up going from like 12 bytes to 12
bits worth of data to represent just
that one vertex but the vertex like the
cube is the cube is such a predictable
shape that you don't really need to like
store all of the individual vertices you
could just send that one chord into the
gpu and then expand it using like a mesh
shader or i mean it doesn't even have to
be that complicated you could just
expand it in the vertex shader i suspect
that's what that means so that's
interesting i think we can definitely
take a look at that although i did
promise architecture in this video is
has to be a finite length unfortunately
so we'll see how far we get okay and
libraries use fast noise light for
terrain generation okay fast noise yep
so it's just like a purlin slash other
noise kind of generation algorithms
packed into there glad for loading open
okay so yeah opengl yeah glad glf wglm
pretty standard i'm going load png which
i haven't heard of i wonder why
you used this instead of just stp image
i guess maybe this is a bit lighter
because it's only png or something but
um maybe it's faster because stp image
is not the fastest thing anyway whatever
let's get into the project okay so what
i've done is i've just cloned it using
git of course and then just built the
project files using cmake and here we go
fail to open file default.chelsea great
start but it seems to work let's take a
look at this oh okay i'm gooey
um
oh okay so escape locks the mouse or i
guess brings up the menu and also
unlocks it okay cool yeah i mean look
this is working and i didn't even have
any problems getting it to build so
that's nice okay we've got the block
outline mouse feels very like sensitive
um
well
place to remove blocks
seems to work let me just dig a tunnel
okay so you can just fly through and yep
you can see that none of the back faces
are being rendered and no blocks that
are actually not visible right so
invisible blocks are not being rendered
at all okay i guess this is how we
select blocks to play so we can just
like
there we go we just have to go to this
and select it very cool ui very uh very
high tech
um uh okay are the speed of this
well the lighting is kind of interesting
because it's not very smooth it's just
like it's as if there's like a few
different states of lighting that's
interesting
enable physics i like how it's in quotes
physics
yeah i guess it's a bit not really
correct physics or something okay so
let's see if we can okay i'm stuck
the physics are beautiful
i can't unfortunately
i can't hold space to jump it's very
annoying
it's so fast i made it very fast
cool i mean yeah it seems to work i'd
love to just be able to uh let's disable
physics um it'd be cool if we could like
fly faster
but i can't seem to get that to work
because i'm interested in like
just flying really really fast and
seeing like how well the terrain
generator can can keep up with that
maybe we'll anyway i'm gonna try and not
turn this into like an optimization
series and like explain how i would do
this better because that's whatever all
right so digging into the code let's see
what we've got so looking at the
projects here so you've separated out
every sub-module into separate
kind of things here which is good i
guess
um oh wow look pantry is quite big
that's interesting stb image is all kind
of in a header file but i feel like all
of the codecs are like the size of all
this codes this is interesting i've
never looked at this library before but
yeah interesting oh well maybe it is
maybe it's nice and fast though
um okay anyway so all these older models
are here but i don't like the fact that
this is called main like why is this
called main
like he could have at least called this
like jailcraft or something but it's
just called main i mean i guess it makes
sense in a way it's kind of it makes it
easy for me to find
but um yeah i'd probably name it
something a bit more sensible and then
we've got all this stuff here
where are like your header files let me
just switch to all to this mode
oh they're just here
where are all of the header files where
are they this is super weird so they're
all here in source they are in fact next
to everything well yeah these are going
to be all linked because it's a cmake
project which means none of these are
probably even relative to
yeah so they're not actually here
they're back at directory inside source
but why the header file's not showing up
that's like super annoying you can't see
the header files here
i don't know man what's going on what's
going on bro like you need to see a
header file alright main.cpp cool let's
let's start kind of taking a look at all
of this architecture okay default.glc so
that was probably the save file that it
failed to load in the very beginning
when it actually tried to i guess load
the save file and it didn't find it sure
so that's kind of the save path and then
we try and load this and then we do
application instance to get the app um
okay cool so you're kind of using like a
singleton approach here
uh i wouldn't do this because it doesn't
seem like it's necessary i also don't
really like the fact that this is just
kind of
so you've made like a static application
it's tight it's tied to
this kind of
it's like a local static thing which
means that the first time this runs it
will actually instantiate it and like i
don't know i use this for like basically
i only use this approach of creating
objects for like debug utils that i want
to like lazy lazy load or lazy
initialize kind of like this application
is such
a like
important part of your
application
that like i
like why not
you know just kind of create it here
like the thing is even if you do it this
way there's nothing to stop you from
like you know
using this as a singleton still right
like you could for example in the
constructor just store like you know so
in the constructor over here we could
have like a static
application you know s instance or
something which we could initialize to
null and then when the constructor
actually gets called the first time then
we could set it to like this i hate this
clang format thing destroying everything
but anyway so you can just set it to
like this right and then that way
obviously you could return that inside
your instance
function or whatever
i i don't know i just don't i just this
doesn't sit well with me and i guess the
reason is that i just think that such an
important part
of your project should it should be
clearly defined
where it actually gets created because
the thing is like again you're not doing
much in your application so it's
probably okay it's probably not a huge
deal and to be honest you'll probably
hear me say that a lot about all this
stuff because i'm just picturing like
when obviously when i see like
application and this is like the whole
application and you run it here right
like i'm kind of in my head i'm
comparing it to maybe like a game engine
like hazel or something right and so
obviously like the application class
there is going to be a lot bigger and
heavier and more important than your
application class which doesn't even
seem to do much stuff in the constructor
however it's still something that like i
would kind of
like from a design point of view it
would be nice to be able to kind of
create it explicitly instead of having
this kind of lazy load situation where
whoever happens to call instance first
it gets created then and also it's not
like
it's not really clear because that's the
other thing right if you if you're
making it this way it's really not clear
at all
when the application destructor will get
called and when the application gets
shut down
because this effectively is a static
variable which means during like static
shutdown or whatever that's when it
would destroy it
which is basically going to be like at
the end of the main function
right but but in no predictable order
now if we quickly compare this to hazel
just for reference then you can see that
like in the main function it's extremely
explicit when the app gets created when
the app gets run and when the app gets
deleted
right this is all very very explicit
because it's such a major part that you
really want to be clear with like okay
it gets created here and i should
initialize everything it gets destroyed
here and everything should be shut down
so that's just something that i would
have liked to have seen here okay
whatever so we create it we set the
scene to whatever the safe path is i'm
assuming if that doesn't in fact like if
it doesn't load or anything because it
can't because a safe path isn't a thing
make shed persistence what on earth is
this persistence
what is this
persistence i guess this is supposed to
be something that
what persists commit chunk and then
it stores the chunk persistence what
what an interesting class name now one
thing that i don't really like about
this okay so from a code style point of
view i would rewrite this class pretty
much entirely like literally i think it
would be faster if i just would show you
how i would how i would write it so
first of all
okay so let's not change the
functionality step one what i would do
is i would move this stuff which is
implicitly private right we can't tell
it's private like there's no private
label here because it's a class which
means that if you don't specify a label
it's private by default i always specify
a label though because that just adds
readability right so that you can
actually see the visibility of your
variables and also because to be honest
it's like a bit of a magic thing magic
in the sense that like well if you don't
specify a label then it's obviously
implicitly private just like it would be
public if it was a struct but then as
soon as you specify a label then
obviously everything is
is public under this label so it's kind
of like a weird state where if you don't
do anything if you don't touch it then
it's going to be private so i don't
really like that so what i would do is i
would always add a label but also i
would move this and store it down here
why
because usually when you look at a class
and this is probably like the kind of
game engine
slash like api maybe developer in me
saying this but i like to look at a
class and see
what its api lets me do
which obviously is the public
contents of that class right so stuff
that is private is kind of an
implementation detail you could say
because i don't like to use this class i
just need to know what functions i can
call basically right or what data it
contains if that data is public
how it works internally and what it
stores and whatever other private
functions it might call itself that is
completely meaningless to me because i
only care about what i can actually use
that's why i personally like to start a
class with the public methods variables
whatever you have an explicit
constructor up here i noticed that
you've you've been making a lot of
constructors explicit like scene i
noticed also had an explicit constructor
don't exactly know why that is i
wouldn't make a constructor explicit
unless it
was like maybe some kind of math type or
something that like i really i mean math
type is actually a good example of
implicit constructors and why you would
want them right but in general like if
there was like a reason to make it
explicit meaning that like there was
some kind of you know implicit
conversion that is common and that was
messing something up or it was like i
don't know it's it's not very common to
be honest that i've had to use explicit
but implicit constructors can just
simplify code a lot and for those who
don't know what an explicit constructor
is it basically means that you can't
implicitly construct this object by
simply specifying this type whereas to
me like that word specifically means
like there's a reason that i've marked
this as explicit because it was raw and
it was messing with some other types
that i didn't want to touch or something
like that okay then we have commit chunk
get chunk so i don't like the fact that
again this destructor it's down here i
like to neatly have my constructors and
destructors all in the same place right
all in one place at the beginning
constructors obviously construct the
object i would have like a copy
constructor here if i needed it you know
i would have a move constructor here if
i needed it all of the constructors are
in one place and the destructor follows
them let's move on to some of the other
source files abb uh access plan okay so
i'm assuming there's gonna be quite a
bit of math stuff there has to be right
because obviously you have to well for
one you have to place and remove blocks
right so there's a ray class here then
we have these axis planes so what on
earth is this
axis plane
playing normal right position right
direction access point okay playing
normal
calculate offset direction so a whole
bunch of math here intersect
dot play normal ray direction so this is
like kind of like a plane equation i'm
assuming that's why you got the plane
plane normal and then this is going to
return i guess the distance of
intersection on there by the way if this
kind of math is confusing to you then
like there's no reason that it has to be
confusing you can just learn all about
it if you head over to brilliant those
of you don't know brilliant is an
amazing website filled with really
really good courses on various stem
topics and i particularly love their
math courses unlike other course
websites brilliance courses are
extremely interactive and engaging they
quiz you they ask you questions about
certain things to make sure that you're
actually learning stuff they give you
like these sliders that you can play
with and just heaps of like interactive
controls so that you can visualize what
you're learning better and to be honest
that's how i learn best visually and by
practice aside from math brilliant also
has a lot of really good computer
science courses on topics such as data
structures and the best thing is that
you can get started with brilliant for
free just go to my link in the
description below and check out their
amazing classes for yourselves and if
you like them brilliant have been
amazing enough to offer the first 200
subscribers who sign up using my link in
the description below 20 off an annual
membership huge thank you to brilliant
for sponsoring this video alright so
taking a look at the ray class what
seems to be happening here is that you
have a constructor not explicit that's
good which takes in a position a
direction and the world and the reach
which i'm assuming is like the maximum
distance of the ray
this is kind of an interesting design
and it's a little bit weird to me
because
like array in my mind just represents
like literally a mathematical like
equation
right like you're casting a ray into the
world and you're seeing what it hits
to me that's like a problem to do with
numbers you're literally doing some
calculating whereas what you're doing is
you're actually passing in the world and
so this is extremely specific
to
this world right so it has to actually i
guess
use the context of this world to figure
out what blocks you can actually hit
and and what you're intersecting with
and then you can see that it's even tied
to like certain things like
air right so if it if it if it hits the
air then obviously that's not a valid
block to hit
so we're not going to set successful to
true and all of this stuff this is
actually a really good example of being
super specific to suit your needs and in
my opinion this is a little bit too far
but if you think about it like array
class could be like the most generic
thing ever right it's just as i
mentioned it's just a mathematical set
of numbers right and then you can do
whatever you want with it maybe you have
a ray versus abb collision test and that
abb maybe is in world space and so you
need to maybe transform it into raised
local space or rain to world space or
whatever right you do all of that
conversion kind of as you need it
however it could be as specific as this
where you literally like when you
construct a ray it immediately actually
does the math
in your specific world knowing all about
your specific block types now why is
this a bad thing well it's not exactly a
bad thing but the reason why it's a bit
weird is because what happens when
for this same game not saying you're
building an engine here but for this
same game you want to like open a door
maybe you add some kind of like
attacking feature and if you're pointing
like towards a mob or an enemy of some
sort you cast out a ray to see if you
hit them and that's going to trigger
something like how exactly are you going
to
you know adapt this red class to deal
with all these cases the constructor
here is just going to keep growing it's
also extremely tightly tied to just
being used for specific blocks and the
class itself just simply can contains
like successful and hit target which i
guess is like
i don't know if this is the position of
the block or the position of the ray hit
on the block but then you've got
obviously blocked data which is like
what kind of block it hits and then like
neighbor information like this is this
is all it's such a specific use case
like at the very least i would just
simply construct a ray you know like
this but then be like maybe make like a
cast function or something and that way
you could have like several
different functions for specific use
cases in your game
but like doing it in the constructor
like this like it's it's too narrow you
know it just it just it has one function
and that's it and again as this
inevitably grows you would have to
refactor it anyway now the other the
other thing that i think is important to
note here is that when i construct an
object i don't generally like it depends
what objective it is if it's like an
application
class instance or like a scene class
right
maybe i expect that constructor to be
somewhat heavy
but if it's like
you know array i don't expect a ray
constructor or any math type really
to be heavy
right because
i'm just constructing a little object
maybe i can reuse it later so for
example if i want to cast a bunch of
rays or i just have like one ray that
permanently looks forward where the
camera is facing and i can kind of
construct that but then i want to
repeatedly cast it i guess what i'm
getting at is i just wouldn't expect the
constructor to cast the ray like
simple as that the other thing is like
again casting like the actual so array
mathematically that representation of
like having kind of like an origin and
direction like that's all fine but when
you start bringing the world into it you
know to me like casting a ray is
something that is it's
it's tied to the world if you think
about it isn't it because if you just
have a ray and then you're trying to
cast this ray and then obviously like
where are you casting it into like
you're not casting it into the void like
you're you exist within an environment
you draw this line within that
environment like here we are we're in a
box
you know where the player over here and
then what do we do we cast this ray
so where is this ray being cast this ray
is being cast and potentially hits like
a block within
this kind of environment right within
this box so this box is in fact the
world now how you've achieved this
effectively
is by creating this ray and then passing
the world into the actual ray class
so that you then know like what objects
is exist within that world or what
blocks exist within that world so that
you can do your kind of collision test
now to me this is just such a backwards
way of thinking about it because to me a
ray just represents this line you know
block represents a block you know player
represents a player they all exist
within the world so i would put that
raycast function
in the world class now we can get really
deep here honestly i could spend hours
talking about like
object oriented programming and like
what to put into what class but at the
end of the day like i think you need to
stop thinking of things as classes and
start thinking of things as functions it
doesn't even matter really what class
it's in the reason why i would put it
into the world is because the world it
has that context it owns the blocks in
the world the player exists within the
world therefore if i mathematically
shoot a ray in the world it has
all of that necessary context to
actually see what the ray hits and where
whereas what you've done here is you're
basically shoving that context down the
ray's throat because it needs all of
this extra data in order to actually
figure out what on earth it's hitting
and what block type stuff is and all
that stuff this this this actually
wouldn't even be that that much of a
tightly kind of coupled function or
whatever if it existed inside the world
class so yeah like as far as this goes
just think of operations such as these
as just like a function try and break
down this project in a way just into its
mathematical roots of like i have a ray
and i need to do a bunch of math on it
to see whether or not it hits certain
blocks and which blocks and how i can
manipulate them and whatever else think
of that as a function think about the
inputs into that function so in other
words stuff like the world the ray
anything else and think about your
expected output of the function right
think of it literally in the most basic
terms possible because at the end of the
day what you're doing is you're making
your cpu execute this kind of function
that is going to take some kind of input
to crunch some numbers generate an
output that basically says hey this was
successful as you were putting it which
basically means i hit something and here
is the associated data that you might
need such as like which block you hit
and then once you've kind of gone
through that in your mind and you know
exactly what you're doing then you can
think about like where does this belong
within my code because again like i mean
maybe you had a great reason for this
i'm just not seeing it and that's
totally fine but to me this just looks
like you just you're just maybe
struggling a little bit with deciding
where code kind of should be and i guess
like how a good way to dress it up is
and to be honest that's like another
huge issue that i notice a lot with
people who are both learning programming
but also kind of maybe get a little bit
too tight tied down into like the object
oriented paradigm and that is the fact
that like
the name of the class begins to
in a way imply certain behaviors and in
your in your mind perhaps you're trying
to like assign certain behaviors to
certain classes if you stop thinking in
that kind of object-oriented way where
you have like a class for each of your
like i don't know high-level nouns in
your like story that is in your uml
diagram and all that absolute rubbish
that people say mostly like
corporate managers and universities
maybe and you start thinking a little
bit more about like the data and what
actually needs to be done and try and
simplify that as much as possible then i
think that you you probably will come up
with
better ways to sort some of this stuff
out now moving on here uh as usual i
think we're running out of time but
let's just let's just like click on some
random files and see what i can find
here okay so the scene class is
something that we use to kind of control
like the game logic because there's also
a world class so this kind of seems a
little bit confusing to me but i think i
kind of get your drift where the world
kind of
contains like the world generator and
i'm assuming all of the actual world
data or maybe that's inside the world
generator and let's just see it and
noise sure
but um i guess all of the actual so
where are the chunks stored uh up here
chunks right so you have our map of
ivec2 which i guess is an is it just an
xy kind of coordinate for that chunk
because the chunks kind of are
two-dimensional in the sense that like
these aren't blocks these are chunks
right
and then uh
we have a ref to a chunk okay so that's
a heap allocated object there and then
we have hashvec2 which is just a
particular hash that you use for that on
ordered map for your um for your ivec 2
sure so the world class again is is is
the thing that specifically
uh stores all of your chunks whereas
scene is kind of like your game manager
and then from there obviously we call
update that updates the player the world
all of that kind of stuff i'm just gonna
briefly look through all of this stuff
what is going on here bro
if key equals 87 or k equals 265
why are you using integers for all this
stuff damn this took a turn so you're
using gel of w which actually comes with
constants for all these things right so
like gl of w key
i don't know w for example
now
if for whatever reason maybe you don't
want to include gl of w in here and
perhaps that's why you're doing this
then that's absolutely not a reason at
all because what i would do is i would
just take
you know all of this stuff copy it
basically put it into a header file
inside your actual project called like i
don't know key codes and then reference
those
because this is just wild having
comments here for like you know for for
just random numbers basically that map
to key codes like that's intense this
kind of like threw me off like i don't
know this is
this is weird because you know all of
your other code just seems
so much kind of you know above this
level where we're still doing this stuff
now
then what you do okay so you have action
action equals one so set is camera
moving forward
and then we
forward dot is moving equals is moving
forward is a movement direction which an
is an is moving followed by direction oh
my goodness what is going on here bro
you really need like a camera tutorial
or like a movement tutorial or something
this is intense you know i always say
that before you google something
you know if you have the time
it's nice to try and implement it
yourself
and i mean back when i first started
programming i used to go crazy with i
used to just i guess force myself to
come up with
my own personal implementation and and
solution to all of these various
problems and some of the solutions i
came up with back when i was like in
high school and had a few months of
programming experience they were whack
they were ridiculous but it was cool
because i was able to actually solve the
problem myself and yes i did it in a
garbage way but i did it myself and i
think that's an important step to
learning so if that's what's going on
here then cool i'm glad you tried this
yourself
now let's talk about why this is weird
and what i would do instead so first of
all
what you probably should do what you are
doing actually is you have a bunch of
predefined vectors
right so this is like the forward
direction which seems to be on the
x-axis then we have backwards right
which is the negative kind of x-axis and
all this stuff you also have boolean
states for all of these which again is a
little bit weird but i can maybe see why
you're doing this i'm assuming it's
because you can move say forward and
left and up at the same time and so
that's why you kind of have these states
here so that you can check to see which
way you're moving but again i don't know
i just don't know why this is happening
because what you could do is you could
just have something like extremely
simple here such as like i don't know
my velocity and we could like just
initialize that to zero or whatever and
then obviously if we move
forward then all we have to do is say
that like we're going to move in
whatever we decide like a forward
direction is which could be like i guess
you were using one at the very end if we
wanted to make sure that you know we
were moving like so let's say we go left
which uh left was
sure on the z axis apparently
um if we did something like that then
like oh no we're moving too fast or
whatever you could always if you wanted
to take this and like
normalize it in the end or something
make sure it's universal that way your
speed really is one no matter how many
directions you're holding not that this
is a good way to write like an fps
camera in general because you would want
to probably move in the direction of the
rotation of the orientation which i'm
assuming you do anyway because obviously
that was working but i guess this is
just like kind of like where is your
intention to move is it forward if so
then set that to true whatever but again
kind of ridiculous i would just do the
calculating actually here and then just
like
basically be like camera dot set
velocity and again it doesn't matter if
we're moving up or down or left or right
or whatever because we know which way
we're moving we have that kind of
mathematical vector instead of this kind
of like logic kind of state tree which
is kind of what you've created here the
other thing is again like just like with
these weird numbers
code is supposed to be self documenting
you want to document the code as much as
possible meaning that when you have
something like this instead of repeating
this
this many times action equals one
clearly means that the key is pressed so
just make a boolean called key pressed
and just set it equal to action equals
one we could just rename this to like is
pressed or whatever and then that way
it's just like is are we moving is is
pressed and i mean you could make it
even less and bigger than that i mean we
have ears moving so you could even set
this to is moving and then that way
obviously we would
you know have his moving here instead of
action equals one
right like what does that mean and i
know what it means but i'm just i'm
saying that it could mean so much more
if you just simply name this variable
just like you should name your key codes
or use like the predefined definitions
for them now because this is a gaming
engine it's interesting to see like
world render for example specifically
using like opengl code like oh that just
feels so so weird to me but like again
that's totally fine
because this whole like the opengl is
basically being used as the render api
for this game you know so it's totally
normal to have stuff like this even
though
you know of course the engine developer
inside me wants to abstract this away
make it generic make it so that we can
implement any render api if we want to
maybe put this at least into a renderer
class or something so that it's like we
can specifically call stuff like
renderer you know enable blending or
whatever if we're not creating pipelines
and specific other things but
totally fine now the last thing i kind
of want to look at is i guess maybe
block vertex or something so because
because you mentioned that see this is
why it's weird right you mentioned you
were doing cool like vertex packing
stuff and yet you've got like this stuff
this is why it's so
so interesting to me like
it's just weird okay so i found the
shaders for
uh drawing the actual blocks and
everything and we've got
default.default.frag here so we've got
the vertex shader here which is quite
quite large and so what it's doing is
it's actually taking in a single
attribute
right just one uint a single unit so we
have four bytes here
and from there you can see that we're
extracting all of the information that
we actually need such as the xz position
of the block uv coordinates flags all of
that stuff by just simply extracting
bytes
from that vertex data right so you can
see like extract byte over here it's
going to basically isolate a specific
but add a specific offset this is i
don't know why you've done it this way
this is actually kind of funny i would
just do like i would just you know move
it by the offset first and then just
ended by ff and sure ffu unsigned
there's no need to like shift this all
the way up mask it out and then shift it
back the other way because if you're
shifting something right then the the
rightmost stuff that already existed
there is going to just drop off anyway
but anyway so we're extracting these
specific bytes so again exit position is
just going to be i guess a value between
0 and 255 same with uv coordinates same
with flags flags are just containing
things like whether or not it's animated
and then we have according to certain
flags and some other stuff that we're
extracting so the y position here has
its own so the first kind of byte i
guess is the y position then the second
byte is the xz position which i'm
assuming yeah is stored kind of
occupying just four bits so between 0
and 15 for both of those things so that
way we kind of we just do some kind of
bit masking and stuff to actually get
the real xyz position which we then use
as our vertex position which eventually
gets multiplied by the model v
projection matrix so basically again
instead of actually having like layer
location called zero blah blah in vec3
you know vertex position and this
obviously right would occupy 12 bytes of
memory because we have three floats each
float is four bytes this whole thing
occupies four bytes of memory and it
doesn't just contain enough data for us
to actually piece together this vertex
position it also contains the uv
coordinates which would be another like
eight bytes right because that would be
a vector and also any other flags that
we might actually use so obviously this
is a huge saving i mean just these two
together without the flags are 20 bytes
of memory whereas this is a five times
reduction because it's only four bytes
so that's what he was talking about in
terms of like just being a little bit
smarter with the way that these this
kind of vertex data inside the vertex
buffer is actually packed so yeah kind
of cool now of course you could go a
little bit more advanced like you i mean
you ultimately don't even need a vertex
buffer you could just have like some
kind of storage buffer and then maybe
like that could be written out by by a
compute shader which will automatically
generate the actual terrain mesh for you
you could really expand this obviously
but it's pretty cool obviously seeing
something that isn't just like at your
standard like in vec 3 position and then
it's just kind of a waste for a voxel
game like this where everything is so
simplified ah this is really making me
want to make like my own minecraft clone
and then over here in the fragment
shader we're able to like do the same
thing kind of with the vertex uv now the
vertex uv is actually interesting
because the the actual like texture
itself obviously this is ultimately like
a sprite sheet we have a coordinate of
something that we want to access right
within that that atlas that texture
atlas so we can divide it by 16 because
one two three four five six seven eight
nine we've got 16 of these here and then
obviously like the vertex uvs are also
kind of going to be predictable because
it's all just arranged in a grid so
everything's really super easy when
you're dealing with voxels and tiles
like this and
uh you know this guy's code has
certainly taken advantage of that which
is awesome to see so yeah overall a
really cool project i enjoyed looking at
it some questionable things and
obviously like the architecture i would
kind of give a little bit more thought
to i didn't take a look at the
performance of this at all and to be
honest i'm kind of glad i didn't not
because i think it's bad or it's slow or
whatever just because i feel like that's
what that's what these code reviews
inevitably become anyway thank you guys
for watching this video if you enjoyed
it please don't forget to hit the like
button below if you want me to take a
look at your code in the next episode of
this code review series and send it into
channelreview gmail.com that email
address and some instructions will be in
the description below overall a really
cool project i enjoyed looking at it
some interesting like decisions when it
comes to architecture that i think you
could improve but otherwise it was
pretty good and the vertex packing stuff
you did is is definitely cool as well
also don't forget to take a look at
brilliant using the link below and i
will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you